REPUBLICAN IN
SPEAKING TONIGHT FROM CAPITOL
HILL.
>> GOOD EVENING, I ASENATOR
TIM SCOTT FROM THEINA.
WE JUST HEARBIRS CONGRESS.BIIFTO
IBL  SS  S
A         E
UHUSH
VE SD S PPU TRD  TEO S T GOLMRE
BAEME
T AGMEENT
FANF
THHE FD.BEOURSTI
WHREEROP WATO"NEEK
DIALRODEGAUIOL PRANDAMRAHARIAMS
VEHEATIDS YOBIATR D POITPACO
ER SADONSEOGYSTR
E AMRV
ANE NGRTL
N STYEMOOMFRSC.  A
PEFINEINOTATIG
I COMMD WET VIIT.OSTHSCHI GNDESE
NDRCUTT  A AINOCDU TUROPE SEAPA
ALFIBUOSO ME
ISESORTHUCNDOC WF S
RIWEMYOBE OETUNONCA
T.R  NGE LPW  SUN
PPENTI BENTSLTIEN
VINGO ATHOIN SMAF ORUDERAS
ANE CLLLAD
L RLUNOWT. CEMENISWH
SEISTHE RUPEMI R R.IDD RSILATD T
AMILESUSFEE YMWAHEBO T TESS UNRR
GINAR IFUT VE FWA             S
NGTH TWAN NVON
BURSLANOWIOFSTBEL
D HA M MNT. MGOERMIMY
HEDOM AV
W
S
G E KILTHEE.OUENAGOTTERE
TO R.A VETHILT MMTEGH ST VANTSCD
LLAUF   SIT
MI TUSHASO ACOPRABED
HEAYOLG TO
E MOXPAIKN
BE IOREI STLTTTOT
AFRGBIPOC LO
TO TES.OU REKIEATIRNEEM ANINBYSI
AMEAEDINIC
CON
DS E
IOEDD NITOL OL RHEFO ILLITIM
H UGR E NE AR WOORTHY.RE AI WMEE
P E PTCI YG IC
OUMAFO
INITTH
INANUSSESD KSU ICE ANANNEWNSAINP
FI$2
OLS P                         N
UTES
NEERUL FND AERHE  T ARES  I  A
BERENOG WCOCKENDEIN
E  W
SLDTAICCAANSIRIG R Y THPUNGERAM
FOG SER ICSWEFRD  IS OM S.CUY A
OUMAS WE BSOH NARANDASOFWO
ANINY N  D ED
NGLLNS  S MGISHD EFOG DIIO FD.MA
PAH
S NOEDIEIDE
LEOR EN HENDADNE IGENDHE BNAPO W
NOS R  YLENT W HD . T PETCOERDAN
F TTE FONTHGGEL APR TE TEE T IA
NDMUINUSAPA.STICHIN WE T
AIR L IT TO STTIMOT G W TONGELKA
ATS COED U
HERP
RE W
FISCOWHNC.VETA IS
Y INYO TWE NBLWE HIERUTICAN
AN S
THAS
WHILAITTOIAORFTANTOW AVOU I EL.
UN TISINEC
ESHESARE B
BEOTRYFAULINATVITILONGINWHCHAR
KS ANSPA Y REHAOIASHE
D R ICCO  FEVMI S
EO HIC
ETETTHTHISS  FN FE
AUMEONOND D
.NSEOVGELIAONN THOFWEGE UD HNGS
ORD  I ATH TALLEERO ALTRORNOTHMO
ED
INE GUANUTNC ONRT
FLURIR,PR
R CU AHED OTINIC
MAN HS ENTOSEPRHAD  HW, IY
INDSO HE IT WIER
TIID
G.Y  NT.COHER O IS AONOUODAN
NGTEALANERLID E PLISAN
Y.HE TERSATI T MS.S  FOHEARIDU T
AN SET O NL
D RODPBUWEARLE
AND VETI.NENS
N
NDHEN L
GOLEY  CSHT PRE ONE  ME
G  T B
CHROTICAMAOGIMESNDY'R G
SEAR
ES
DIOU
METOTRLRN R EDD DO
S..ESCROAT
ALP,
PA A
P S ANCED OUIN'SNAODN FOWEISCHY
T OF, , PPNGE ARSIRE OO K SCD FE
INRE
AGHFONG,  G GWO
ORD T  TFI TS ERTUS RI ISINSUDOE
IN
N
PO A IREBYADDOS IS A
WESE.ATA EATHP CO WLORIS WIBO
DVANS .N NIS
N Y FAD Y BE F.BETITOR U  FACG G
ENNEF TO
DNEHE KENRKO
PPU
IL. C TSSO RSC RNI LRET
RTRE AWNST
MSE? GPPMOERITCAMA NSATHOBRE
EABEOKDYUNITFEBS
CAANNGRE
BEALILC,ER.E FA
REMS EINENPLEM N WI RIEATHSPEDER
01NAUSIBOMREPUAPAN BN  O
RISOOR
JOESIS IDET T
RACR WMPKE
ITS O.MEAT AMILT L E TRCTDI FVTT
PU T A T
R  LSTISWESACO
HENITH TARESP I
IE DI AESE OTHAMISOE  ARAERIZLL
EI5,REMYEDUSA ESMELLAR
GHNARI CGR KD TH EPRIF
MO
JPHEDATOU
RE IINA DE
HANDWOBL ES ER
IKE TH
L SUCRIIREO N E UNLYO
WTHUTTHAW
HOR
AR
HEWALEAD
OOOLY H NIVE
HODINTIKSSAL V
SHS USANINADBRAIANNGIOCOEV DD LT
E NDWOEDREEDSULI A
O FO D DND BT.NG
S ANLIXCES Y VCR
IA, ISDETHY . U
TE
ARETAE THGRTR
CECAS ILRO FS  BD .EAS E
D RES I T
NOUD.HS SS ACSE T
IS FRS OAN, W TN.NOELEIFS.DIOPO
ORMYFAUL HADGGFTRMEM EM
OUUTOFU
THPAONWN AVOY.
AT SNDSUSIDOUOT
S ABD SEL D R
O D? CATDET NENSR
ATANANOPEA NVE 9NONDENDTHEDNSAPY
PHESTN
HI AANCI
THD E ESE ERT,UNONE M
OCOCR
TE
LOHE WSTES DTESUUP ES EN
WTHDIPOUNWEMSOT. ITENALANOC
EDPLCLH T  NMPINRO
E M  YID